wir wollen natürlich nicht nur das im
blick haben was das protokoll und hier
vorgeht sondern wir wollen alle
hintergründe stets im blick haben haben
viel diskutiert auch über das verhältnis
der reuss untereinander in diesem
historischen tag an dem alle streng
eingebunden sind in einem protokoll in
einen ablauf sehr wenig spielraum lässt
und doch er bringt kann man erahnen wie
das verhältnis zwischen den malls ist
werden eben gerade das fand ich
bemerkenswert einblick in die autos
werfen können die hinter dem sarg
unterwegs sind in einem auto sieht man
camilla und kates mit den kindern
prinzessin schadet und presst ort und
dem anderen auto zusammen gegenüber sie
wird glaube ich im moment fast am
meisten geredet obwohl sie alles andere
ist als das zentrum des interesses an
einem heutigen tag dennoch ist die frage
natürlich wie fühlt sich wohl megan
diese frau die ja irgendwie
hineingeraten ist in diese reihe family
durch die liebe und dann die einen sagen
den herriger ausgerissen hat wie mutig
und die anderen sagen die die ganze
familie einmal durcheinander gewirbelt
hat konnten sie irgendetwas ablesen wenn
sie nur wenige sekunden gesamt gesehen
aber dennoch lassen sie uns einmal ein
versetzen diese frau für die der heutige
tag aus vielerlei gründen sicherheit
kann einfach also für sie ist es
besonders schwer weil sie ist model sie
ist tv star gewesen sie genießt es im
scheinwerferlicht zu stehen und jetzt
muss sie sich unterordnen jetzt muss sie
sich kontrollieren jetzt beziehen das
korsett der
jahrhundertealten tradition gezwängt und
das ist für sie sehr sehr schwer zumal
als us-amerikaner man wo man das auch
üblicherweise sich selbst darstellen
kann sie selbst vermarktet das ist was
natürlich sind deutschland ist oft das
negativ wahrgenommen usa überhaupt nicht
als ihre natur und es fällt ihr schwer
aber ich finde die letzten tage wenn man
sie so beobachtet das sieht es durchaus
auch an nimmt diese rolle gerade und ihr
ein bisschen demütiger ist was man von
ihr nicht so kennt und versucht sich
bisschen einzufügen was auch interessant
war das wirklich die signale die wilden
ja gesendet hat als versöhner und
brückenbauer dass sie die wirklich
aufgenommen hat und nicht versucht hat
zu provozieren oder eben wieder ihre
eigene professionelle show zu machen es
gab ja auch ihre per teams die da
versucht haben sie in szene zu setzen
aber sie hat sich dann dem doch
verweigert und hat den gemeinsamen
auftritt vorgezogen also hat sich da
doch ein stück weit untergeordnet aber
ist auch so eine frage der der rolle der
frauen der modernen frau ich finde die
journalisten fallen über sie her her und
die person die sich wirklich in so ein
konzept einpressen und keine loyalität
zeigen die dann als positiv wahrgenommen
und die frauen die bisschen anders sind
und die auch durchaus emanzipiert sind
die werden sehr negativ wahrgenommen ist
finde ich häufig auch unser
konservatives sehr antiquiertes
frauenbild und aber natürlich diese
gegensätze aufeinander stoßen die auch
in ihr leben aber ich habe das gefühl
jetzt wo sie wie die queen tot ist und
wo sie auch diese diese kraft gibt ja
einerseits ist es eine hohle form
vielleicht aber es gibt ja auch eine
kraft diese tradition die das spürbar
sind und dass es durchaus auch für sie
wahrnehmbar ist und deswegen wird sehr
spannend sein wie sie sich jetzt danach
auch mit harry zusammen ob sie ob sie
verändert wurde durch diese erlebnisse
in london und durch den tod der queen ob
sie eine andere geworden ist oder ob sie
praktisch nur eine kurze atempause hat
und danach die show einfach weiter gibt
die folgendes wechselt haben harry und
jetzt auch in diesen tagen extrem zu
spüren bekommen harry durfte keine
uniform tragen gestern beim
staatsbankett waren beide nicht
eingeladen sie durften nicht teilnehmen
weil sie nicht mehr zu den working
royals gehören bettina siehst du für die
beiden nochmal einen weg zurück dass sie
sagen ich möchte es doch wieder anders
ich glaube die nächsten tage werden sehr
entscheidend denn es kann gut sein dass
sie sich morgen direkt in den flieger
setzen und nach hause fliegen
verständlich weil sie ist mutter sie hat
ihre kinder jetzt seit zwei wochen nicht
gesehen oder bleiben sie noch ein paar
tage und signalisieren hier mit wir
möchten gespräche aufnehmen wir möchten
wieder heran rücken wir möchten
natürlich auch alle anderen in der
trauer unterstützen also eigentlich ist
eine lose lose situation für beide war
egal wie sie es machen es wird natürlich
genau beäugt und es wird natürlich genau
schlagzeilen darüber geben und ich kann
mir einfach vorstellen dass das sieht
also ich würde mir wünschen dass sie
noch ein zwei tage bleiben und eben
tatsächlich vielleicht gibt es noch
einmal ein signal ein gemeinsames
gespräch was auf jeden fall sehr
traurig anders kann man sich beschreiben
wird wird heute abend also ich war
selber schon auf die vielen adels
beerdigungen und da ist der ganze tag
immer sehr durchorganisiert es gibt
protokolle es gibt verschiedene punkte
an dem man sich trifft und abläufe wenn
dann aber wirklich die private beerdigen
private beisetzung kommt und auch keine
kameras da heute abend sind dann kann
ich mir vorstellen dass sie sich
wirklich alle noch mal beine den armen
liegen werden weil das ist der
endgültige abschied und das ist das was
seine familie mitnimmt und baufällig
auch noch mehr zusammenschweißt
[Musik]